people don't show up for one of three
reasons number one is you're afraid
you're afraid of rejection you're afraid
of failure you're afraid of it not
working out and so you just don't show
up number two is you're not consistent
you show up some days but you don't show
up other days because you don't have the
routines and habits in place to make you
show up consistently every single day
and number three is you don't want to
you don't want to show up because you
don't actually enjoy the thing that
you're about to do you would rather
procrastinate on it because you don't
love it and showing up is more painful
than just sitting around